[Musique]
juste là myrtho adjudant chef des
sapeurs pompiers professionnels et
président de l'union des
sapeurs-pompiers de la réunion s'est vu
remettre l'insigne de chevalier de
l'ordre national du mérite ce samedi 30
décembre à la mairie de saint-paul une
médaille remise par le colonel eric
faure président de la fédération
nationale des sapeurs-pompiers de france
en présence de cyril melchior président
du département et du conseil
d'administration du 6 9 7 4 de joseph
sinimalé maire de saint paul et du
colonel hervé berthou un directeur
départemental du 6 9 7 4
le sa médaille récompense le fruit de
dix années de travail en tant que
président d'union avec mon équipe avec
la mise en place d des formations pour
les jeunes sapeurs pompiers tous les
samedis et pendant quatre ans donc aussi
défendre les intérêts des sapeurs
pompiers soit au niveau local ou
national des formations pour des
formations des gestes de premiers
secours pour 1500 personnes par an la
médaille que je viens de recevoir si
vous voulez je la dédie s'en est suivi
la signature de la convention de
partenariat entre la section
départementale de l'association
nationale des membres de l'ordre
national du mérite
le mot l'union des sapeurs-pompiers de
la réunion puis cette matinée s'est
achevée par la remise officielle du
chèque aux référents téléthon de la
réunion dans les jardins de la mairie de
saint paul
[Musique]